- I'm here hanging with
former first lady, Laura Bush,
who's on the line from Texas.
So Mrs. Bush, your daughter,
Barbara and her husband
ended up moving home to Texas
while everyone was in
quarantine just for a bit.
So what did you do with
the family back home?
- She was in graduate school
and her graduate school had gone virtual.
So she was on Zoom, of course, all day.
But we were at the ranch. This was sort of
at the very beginning
of the COVID shutdown.
and so,
so we went for long walks.
That's what we love to do,
and then we watched a lot of
different series on television.
- Oh, definitely.
- That's our new entertainment.
- Oh, absolutely. Netflix. It was a wonder
during the pandemic, so it helped us all.
So what's your favorite
way to spoil Jenna's kids?
And what does Jenna
have to say about that?
Y'all got all that hang time.
- Yeah, exactly. Well, our
favorite thing to do with them
which I don't know if
she's thrilled about,
but we love for them to come in early
in the morning and get in bed with us.
I don't know when we're
staying together, I don't know
if you ever saw those old
photographs of the Bushes
in bed with everyone, the
entire family, all their kids
around them in Maine, but we've
carried on that tradition.
So Mila and Poppy come
get in bed very early,
before Jen and Henry are
up, and then of course
what they want to do is get
our iPads and work on them.
So now my iPad, my wallpaper
is a picture of my two cats.
Mila knew how to do that.
Another background is
a picture of our dog.
Mila knew how to set it up that way.
So it's actually been an advantage
for them to play on my iPad.
- Oh my gosh, my children as well, I'm 39
but my six year old can
navigate it better than I can.
It's crazy, and I'm like, how
do you know this password?
And she, somehow, she knows it.
But do you have any favorite
Texas family traditions?
- Texas family traditions?
We go to the Texas state fair.
- Oh, well that's a given.
Yes. Do you eat fried there?
Do you eat like the funnel cakes?
Do you go for it?
- No, not really.
But one year when Barbara
and Jenna were little
and we lived in Dallas and we went
to the Texas state fair
and Jenna was chosen to
be the red pig cheerleader
at the pig races.
That was amusing.
(laughter)
- I am totally bringing that
up the next time we talk.
Oh, that's awesome.
But since we're both Texans
I think we have time for a quick game
we are calling Lone Star Love.
(upbeat country music)
Lone Star Love
I'll say something that's truly Texan
and we will share if we've ever done it.
Here we go.
Had a family member who created their own
homemade barbecue sauce.
(laughs)
- No, I haven't had that
but my dad's best friend
in Midland owned Johnny's barbecue.
- Oh!
- The barbecue joint in Midland.
So he spent a lot of time at,
at Johnny's barbecue and he
would mainly pick up and,
bring it home for us to eat at home.
- Oh, that's awesome.
I don't have anybody in my family
but I definitely have a couple of friends.
Okay. So have you ever told
someone it's pronounced
(laughs)
told someone it's
pronounced pecan, not pecan.
- No, but I've always used pecan.
- Me too,
and everybody, yeah
I think it's like any Georgia friend
or anybody, they say pecan,
and I'm like, "It's pecan".
It's not tomato, tomato. It's pecan.
- [Laura] It's pecan.
- [Kelly] It's pecan.
We made it so.
Okay. So have--I say this all the time.
Have you ever said "All y'all"
because "Y'all" just isn't enough?
I, yeah.
You probably don't.
- Sure, all y'all.
- You do? Okay.
- No, I say "all y'all".
- Okay.
- I mean, I say "y'all"
and I say "all y'all".
- Yeah, okay, me too. I feel,
okay, I feel cooler now.
I thought I was going to feel less than
when you answered that.
(laughs)
Okay. Saying "Deep in the heart of Texas"
in front of the Alamo.
- No, I haven't done that. But I will
the next time I go to San Antonio.
- I know, now it's a challenge,
to both of us I feel,
at this point. I've
never done that either.
I love that that was, I love that people
in my staff thought that
Texans might do that.
(laughs)
That's my favorite part.
Okay. You've gone from
Texas to Texas on vacation.
Have you ever done that?
- Yes, sure. Of course.
- Yeah. Just like a road trip?
- Growing up, we went to El
Paso or we went to San Antonio
or we went to Houston or, you
know, you just would drive
from Midland to all
those different places.
That was your vacation.
- That's so cool. We didn't. Nope.
She was just like, "Have
fun in the backyard.
In the woods. Create your own adventure."
We didn't do--no, you know,
we went to Galveston once
when I was a little kid
and I thought we had hit
the lottery. Yes. I thought,
I thought it was the
most amazing thing ever.
Okay. Admitted that Fort
Worth is better than Dallas.
You might not, but I will.
- No, I live in Dallas.
- I know. Well, I'm from
- I live in Dallas, and Dallas
is better than Fort Worth.
- No, ma'am.
(laughs)
No, I'm just kidding. I'm just kidding.